معنى ان نجيب الخشم وفد فونز 24 الى بالي
الاندونيسيه اهلا بك نجيب اذا استمعنا اذا
الى هذه الكلمه لرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
التي دعا من خلال هي الوحدات لمواجهه
التحديات الدوليه جرت ايضا الاجتماعيه تعد
داخل هذه القمه قمه العشرين ربما سؤالي عن
تقييم وحوصل لهذه الاجتماعات وربما
الاجراءات الملموسه التي خرجت بها هذه
القمه
نعم رغم ان هذه القمه لم تصل الى حلول
جذريه سواء على الصعيد العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه او على همم على صعيد الملف
الاوكرانيه الى هناك ان هناك اجواء تهدئه
همم بين الصين وامريكا وهناك يعني
للوصول الى حلول لا تتعلق بتداعيات الازمه
الاوكرانيه خصوصا على سلاسل الغذاء الرئيس
الفرنسي يتحدث كثيرا عن الدور الاوروبي
القوافل الغذاء همم اتجاه اوكرانيا وايضا
البيان الختامي اشاره الى مبادره المجموعه
العربيه في هذا الصدر كما ايضا اثناء
الدوره التركي في فتح المجال امام وتوصل
للانتفاقات التي يعني دعاء همم
بين روسيا واوكرانيا بشكل غير مباشر طبعا
عبر الامم المتحده وتركيا همم للاستمرار
في همم تصدير همم الحبوب والمواد الغذائيه
من اوكرانيا عبر المواعن الاخرانيه همم
الموضوع الموضوع الغذاء اخذ حيزا كبيرا
جدا من البيان الختامي همم يعني القاده
هنا لديهم شعور في ان هذه القضيه ملحه جدا
وان مناطق في العالم هي على شفير همم
المجاعه
ويعني هناك حتى اشاره الى يعني واضحه الى
التزام الدول المتقدمه اقتصاديا ادعم
الدول الاقل تقدم الدول الناميه والدول
الفقيره في همم اهداف حتى جزر المحيط
الهادئ لمواجهه هذه الازمه والمواجهه
التغييرات المناخيه همم الكبيره همم اعتقد
ان هناك عده مبادرات هامه سوف تتحول الى
خطوات عمليه خلال الفتره المقبله تبدا من
هذه القمه همم مثلا مبادره الانتقال
العادل للطاقه والتي تعني ان الدول
المجتمع وهنا سوف تدعم الدول في مختلفه
انحاء العالم همم الانتقال من همم يعني
توليد الطاقه اعتمادا على الكحه من
المصادر بها الى همم وسائل اكثر اصتدام
همم هناك ايضا التوجه لي همم اقامه
التعاون رقم بين الحكومات لمواجهه القضايا
التي اصبح من الواضح انها لا يمكن ان تحل
على صعيد همم وطني او حتى اقليمي ومن ذلك
مثلا مبدا الصحه الواحده مما يعني ان
الازمات الصحيه ايضا ستكون ازمات همم
عابره للحدود كما راينا مع الجهه
الفيروسيه هناك اذا يعني استعداد كبير
للتعاون ويعني اليات جديده مطروحه همم
ننتظر تطبيقها بعض هذه القمه